los problemas que hemos visto hasta el
momento han ocurrido en una sola
dimensión hemos ido hacia adelante o
hacia atrás hacia la derecha o la
izquierda o arriba o abajo lo que quiero
que veamos en este vídeo es qué sucede
cuando extendemos esto a dos dimensiones
oa tres oa cuatro oa un número
arbitrario de dimensiones aunque si
trabajamos con la mecánica clásica sólo
tendremos un máximo de tres dimensiones
y si vamos a trabajar con más de una
dimensión especialmente si trabajamos en
dos dimensiones trabajaremos con
vectores en dos dimensiones que
comprendamos al menos lo básico de los
vectores de dos dimensiones recordemos
que un vector es algo que tiene una
magnitud y una dirección lo primero que
quiero hacer es tener una comprensión
visual de cómo se suman los vectores
imaginemos que tengo un vector acá que
le voy a llamar vector a aquí la
magnitud está especificada por la
longitud de la flecha y la dirección va
a estar especificada por la punta de
esta flecha digamos que tenemos otro
héctor que lo voy a llamar vector b y es
más o menos así y lo que quiero que
hagamos es ver qué pasa cuando sumamos
el vector a con el vector b hay un par
de cosas a tomar en cuenta cuando cuando
trabajamos con vectores de manera visual
lo importante aquí es por ejemplo para
el vector a que mantengamos la misma
magnitud y la misma dirección este es el
vector a también tiene la misma longitud
que éste y apunta en la misma dirección
no importa en donde lo dibujé siempre y
cuando mantenga estas dos cosas este
vector va a ser el mismo que este
también puedo dibujar el vector a aquí
también puedo dibujar el vector ve por
acá
sigue siendo el vector b porque tiene la
misma magnitud y sigue apuntando a la
misma dirección estos dos son iguales y
noten que el origen de este vector no
tiene por qué comenzar en el origen del
vector a si quiero puedo dibujar el
vector b aquí
no importa este es el mismo vector
simplemente lo estoy desplazando lo
puedo desplazar siempre cuando se
mantenga la misma magnitud y la misma
dirección será en el mismo vector y
estoy haciendo todo esto para ayudarnos
a entender cómo se suman vectores de
manera visual si yo quisiera sumar el
vector a con el vector b y veremos cómo
hacer esto de manera analítica en
futuros vídeos aquí puedo dibujar el
vector
este es mi vector y ahora puedo dibujar
el vector b pero pondré el origen del
vector b en la punta del vector a así
que voy a desplazar el vector b de
manera que su origen esté en la punta de
mi vector
y si vamos del origen de a hacia la
punta debe toda esta parte y a esto lo
llamamos el vector c éste será la suma
del vector a y el vector b y esto tiene
sentido si ustedes piensan en estos
vectores como en desplazamientos nos
dice que nos desplazamos esta cantidad
en esta dirección y b nos dice que nos
desplazamos que esta cantidad de esta
magnitud en esta dirección
a partir de donde estábamos al final de
a si tenemos el desplazamiento de a más
el desplazamiento de b cuál va a ser
nuestro desplazamiento total pues si
estamos aquí vamos a desplazarnos en
esta dirección esta distancia y a partir
de aquí nos desplazaremos así de lejos
en esta dirección así que la cantidad
neta que nos desplazamos es esto y es
por eso que esta es la suma de estas dos
y podemos usar esta misma idea para
descomponer cualquier vector en dos
dimensiones y
en sus componentes vertical y horizontal
vamos a explicar esto en un momento si
yo aquí tuviera un vector que le voy a
llamar vector x yo puedo decir que este
vector x es la suma de un vector
horizontal que llega hasta acá que
dibuje en verde y de otro vector
vertical que estoy dibujando en magenta
noten que x inicia en el origen del
vector verde y x termina en la punta del
vector magenta
además el vector magenta comienza en la
punta del vector verde y termina en
donde termina el vector x la razón por
la que hago esto que yo espero que a
partir de este análisis ustedes lo
comprendan mejor es que el vector verde
más el vector magenta me va a dar el
vector x
el vector verde está en el origen del
vector magenta la razón por la que estoy
haciendo esto es que si puedo expresar x
como la suma de estos dos vectores
entonces habré descompuesto x en sus
componentes horizontal y vertical puedo
llamar a este su componente vertical
xd y a este de abajo su componente
horizontal x h otra forma que puedo
dibujar esto es desplazar este vector
hacia acá recuerden que no importa en
donde dibujemos el vector siempre y
cuando se respete la magnitud y la
dirección este vector es el mismo que
este este es x b
así que vemos que podemos expresar este
vector x podemos expresar este vector x
como la suma de sus componentes
horizontal más su componente vertical y
veremos en repetidas ocasiones que esto
es algo muy poderoso porque nos permite
descomponer un problema en dos
dimensiones en dos problemas de una
dimensión cada uno uno actuando en la
dirección horizontal y otro actuando en
la dirección vertical veamos esto de una
manera matemática pues hemos estado
hablando de la longitud y todo eso pero
veamos cómo descomponer matemáticamente
estos elementos
veamos qué significa descomponer esos
elementos de un vector imaginemos que
tengo un vector así
le voy a llamar a y va a tener una
longitud de 5
la longitud de mi vector a es igual a 5
vamos a indicar su dirección dando el
ángulo con el que este vector se eleva
con respecto a la horizontal vamos a
dibujar unos ejes por acá para que se
comprenda digamos que este es mi eje
vertical este de aquí y aquí tengo mi
eje horizontal x la parte positiva de mi
eje xy la parte positiva de mi eje y
para especificar la dirección de este
vector voy a tener este ángulo de acá y
este ángulo va a tener una medida
bastante peculiar que la elegí con un
propósito muy particular va a estar en
grados para que todas las cantidades al
final sean fáciles de manejar está en
grados y es 36.8 99 grados
elegí este número particular por una
razón en particular lo que quiere hacer
es encontrar los componentes horizontal
y vertical de este vector quiero
descomponerlo en algo que vaya
directamente hacia arriba y otra cosa
que sea completamente horizontal como
hacer esto puedo expresarlos visualmente
para ver cómo lucen su componente
vertical se verá algo más o menos así y
su componente horizontal se verá más o
menos así el componente horizontal
iniciará en dónde está el origen del
vector y llega tan lejos en la dirección
x como la punta del vector pero solo en
la dirección horizontal en la dirección
de x y para llegar a la punta del vector
a tendremos que usar nuestro componente
vertical y podemos llamarle al
componente vertical
porque va paralelo al eje y y podemos
llamar al componente horizontal a equis
porque está en la dirección de x ahora
lo que quiero hacer es encontrar la
magnitud del componente allí y la
magnitud de a x como hacemos esto bueno
lo que hemos dibujado aquí en esencia es
un triángulo rectángulo este es un
ángulo recto y de este triángulo
rectángulo conocemos la longitud de su
hipotenusa que es la magnitud de este
vector y ya habíamos visto que ésta es
igual a 5 así que la magnitud de este
vector a es igual a 5 que eso ya lo
habíamos visto aquí como encontramos la
magnitud de estos lados pues vamos a
usar un poco de trigonometría básica si
conocemos el ángulo y conocemos la
hipotenusa podemos encontrar estos lados
como encontramos el valor del lado
opuesto al ángulo este es el lado
opuesto al ángulo y si se nos olvidó
algo de nuestra trigonometría básica
aquí lo podemos recordar vamos a usar
nuestro sol acá
tohá se no es igual al opuesto entre la
hipotenusa jose no es igual a la
adyacente entre la hipotenusa tangente
si vale lo opuesto entre el adyacente
así que aquí tenemos el ángulo queremos
el opuesto y tenemos la hipotenusa así
que podemos decir que el seno el seno
del ángulo 36.8 99 grados va a ser igual
a la magnitud de nuestro lado opuesto al
ángulo que es la magnitud de a g
entre la magnitud de la hipotenusa y
aquí tenemos que la magnitud de la
hipotenusa es de 5 si multiplicamos
ambos lados por 5 nos va a quedar 5 seno
de 36.8 99 grados que es igual a la
magnitud
el componente que hay en nuestro
componente vertical de nuestro vector a
antes de sacar la calculadora y
encontrar el valor de esto voy a hacer
lo mismo para encontrar la magnitud de
mi componente horizontal a x ya habíamos
visto que este lado de aquí es adyacente
al ángulo conocemos la hipotenusa y el
coche no utiliza el adyacente y la
hipotenusa así que sabemos que el coseno
de 36.8 99 grados va a ser igual a la
magnitud de este componente horizontal a
x que es el cateto adyacente al ángulo
va a ser la magnitud de a x
y va a estar dividido entre la magnitud
de la hipotenusa que ya hemos visto es 5
nuevamente multiplicamos ambos lados de
esta igualdad por 5 y nos queda 5 x
coseno de 36.8 99 grados igual a la
magnitud de mi componente horizontal a x
pues vamos a encontrar el valor de esto
vamos a sacar la calculadora
asegurémonos que está en modo de grados
y ahora estamos listos para hacer los
cálculos el componente vertical es igual
a 5 por el seno de 36.8 99 grados que si
esta cantidad la redondeamos a las
unidades nos va a quedar 3 así que la
magnitud de nuestro componente vertical
es igual a 3 y hagamos lo mismo para
nuestro componente horizontal sacamos de
nuevo a la calculadora y ahora vamos a
tener 5 por coseno de 36.8 99 grados y
si de nuevo esto lo redondeamos a las
unidades nos va a quedar que es igual a
4 así que este componente horizontal va
a ser igual a 4 y así tenemos un
triángulo clásico 345 un triángulo
pitagórico la magnitud de nuestro
componente horizontal es 4 la magnitud
de nuestro componente vertical es 3 y ya
teníamos que la magnitud de nuestro
vector original es de 5
me pueden decir bueno pues para qué nos
sirve esto veremos en los próximos
vídeos que si decimos que algo tiene una
velocidad en esta dirección de 5 metros
por segundo podremos descomponer esto en
dos velocidades podremos decir que este
es el componente vertical de esa
velocidad con esta dirección a tres
metros por segundo y también va a ir en
esta dirección a la derecha en la
dirección horizontal a cuatro metros por
segundo así que nos permite descomponer
el problema en dos problemas de una sola
dimensión cada uno que son muchos más
sencillos de resolver que el problema de
dos dimensiones